[Music]
3d printing technology is I want to say
the greatest thing ever but it's pretty
great so the other word you're gonna
start seeing a lot more of I think is
additive manufacturer 3d printing is
kind of a specific style where you do
layers but I think you'll see other
additive manufacturing schemes involving
different fluids and materials that are
buoyant in those fluids and then extract
that in shapes see a shape sir can be
created that are not possible impossible
to create by subtractive manufacturer
which is what I was brought up with as
an engineer you cut threads in a piece
of metal or plastic to get a threaded
fastener you hollow something out I
often think about the astronauts rock
boxes so they took boxes to the moon to
put rocks in and bring them back to the
earth in hermetic or sealed fashion and
in order to get the boxes to be
lightweight the machinist term is they
were Hogg doubt so they started with a
piece of aluminum this big hollowed the
whole thing out with a milling machine
chips of aluminum just go on the shop
floor to get this thin but yet very very
strong final shape well in the future or
maybe this afternoon no one's gonna very
few of us will manufacture objects like
that subtractive Lee instead this will
be made additively and it will be
lighter weight cheaper less waste and it
will enable many many people to
participate in the additive
manufacturing manufacturing process and
then if you have a problem at home where
something's broken pick a thing your
toaster you'll go online find a new
toaster control knob maybe of maybe a
family of designs you'll pick the one
that you like you'll go to the spiritual
equivalent of FedEx Kinkos and they'll
have an additive manufacturing machine
there if you need it really
sophisticated you'll call a more
sophisticated additive manufacturing
machine shop and they'll make the thing
for you
you will not waste the toaster you will
not throw it away you will not waste
nearly as much material or hardly any
material in the additive manufacturer of
the new knob or piece or a heater wire
and this will allow us to do more with
less this is democratising manufacturer
in the same way perhaps that art is
democratized people can make music now
people can mix hundreds of musical
tracks at home people can go to the
store and buy paint brushes and paint
and canvas or you can electronically
create it and then print I mean this is
democratizing manufacture in a more
efficient way and I think there'll be a
very near future where people will look
around people from my business of
mechanical engineering will look around
at objects and go used to waste all that
metal and all that plant uses leave it
on the shop floor the humanity and so as
that technology matures because there so
the odd the advantages are so obvious
that more and more people get in the
business it will lower the cost of
everything I have a juicer that belonged
to my neighbor who died when she was 86
and the the the business end the the
thing that really does the reaming is
chipped man I look forward to the day
when I can scan that and then additively
manufacture a new one and just put it
right on the old machine I can see it
it's probably possible now if I put in
enough energy finding the right machine
shop I could probably do it right now
but I got other things going on I got to
do this right here for example
[Music]
you